Oh  Britney Spears is surprising admission  the singer reveals she doesn't listen to  her own music oh god I fix me nervous  think about it quote it's funny because  I don't really listen to my own music  the 34 year old is taking the whole God  new look to a new level closing for  flaunt magazine and a metallic crown on  themes she even talks about her  spirituality telling the mag quote I'm a  very spiritual person I believe in  heaven I believe we're all here for a  reason though Britney also says  listening to her songs nightly comes  with a territory of having an ongoing  residency in Las Vegas she adds I'm  about the creative process and then I  put it out there I'm all about change  and new and forthcoming it's really kind  of cool to be able to do that